Regarding intervention or the West
should do.
I think,
yes,
I'm in an ideal situation.
I would agree that a humanitarian corey
doors,
safe zones,
uh,
you name it,
no fly zones,
brilliant,
but it's never going to happen and it's
never going to happen because I think
the United States,
uh,
has reached the conclusion that a choice
to topple Michelle said,
then let's be quite clear.
I mean,
if the United States,
NATO gets involved,
I think the regime will crumble very
quickly,
but a quick crumbling of the regime or
the collapse of the regime will
inevitably lead to a prolonged the
Lebanon style civil war because
potentially the partition of Syria and
this is a very real prospect by the way.
So should we interpret you saying that
as meaning that your urging us to be
careful what we wish for.
In a way,
you're saying that if the,
if the regime collapses,
it's not wholly a good thing.
Well to be a realistic,
even in regime collapse a look that the
region probably has probably about 2
million hardcore supporters.
And again,
I'm being very realistic and very honest
with you.
There are,
Jim does have those people and those,
I mean Gaddafi didn't have 2 million
people,
a hardcore sport is not robotic,
but by Sharon does and that's the
primary reason why he's still in power
and those 2 million people are simply
going to go away.
They're going to stay in Syria,
they probably going to fight,
they're going to reinforce their own
areas and they're probably going to
fight against the central government.
Whoever takes control in Damascus.
So you know,
we have to be realistic about this.
What can be done immediately.
I think the West can perhaps through the
Qataris and the Saudis for instance,
they can support local military councils
and they are being set up to organize
the free Syrian army on a local level
and they can spot those people.
Problem is the Jordanians and the Turks
won't allow a arms in,
don't even allow humanitarian aid
through their border.
Um,
so this is a big,
big logistical problem.
You can,
you can pay FSA,
fight salaries,
but I mean,
I don't say,
I don't see how that,
that,
that's going to help you need weapons.
So particular type of.
Okay,
we're good.
Come to the JC,
your,
the proposal you would support is the
same as Roger Korean's arming the
opposition?
Yeah,
I mean look,
as long as she believes that he can win
militarily and at the moment he does
believe he can win militarily,
then there will be no political solution
and ultimately there has to be a
political solution.
There can be no,
no other,
no other solution.
So it's about forcing by.
Charlotte said to sit on the negotiating
table and he'll only do that if he faces
and armed opposition that could
seriously fight him at least to a
stalemate.
Absolutely.